you might want to open your eyes because
our coast usually writes
oh
relax we can take the bus back great is
gw paying the fare
don't worry we're all mad here i'm
definitely getting mad
i don't want to say it out loud because
then it might be real and i really don't
want it to be real i would say no way
but then again we talked to book
characters so
anything's possible it gives me such
great happiness to see you again oh
right well now that's out of the way
can we just tell her that she's from a
book no way it's too weird
can't just give us a quiet night off
could you go sweating
my grandma wants us to go to a wild
tiger and talk to him
not it i have a life outside of finding
missing book characters good for you
well
this is the end at least i made my bed
this morning
i didn't
well gw
left us a pretty good cliffhanger
we're just uh
[Music]
yeah i got nothing
hello what did you mean by that
nothing i just meant hello as in
hello
well that didn't work no kidding
sherlock
take curtis's bed where am i gonna sleep
i don't know the
floor i just remember that i have a um
a trampoline trampoline listen
be sure you fit into the world of humans
how am i doing
could be better
well played i know
i mean thanks this is gonna be like
finding a needle in a haystack
[Music]
hey thanks ghostwriter there is one
thing i don't understand there's more
than one thing you can't understand joan
you can't understand german or fringe
no
uh-huh
i think she's on to us yes siobhan she
knows we're talking to fictional
characters it's a little hard to believe
i travel through time on a transforming
pirate ship i'm an expert in heart to
believe
just make sure you don't like barricade
yourselves inside an elevator or
something that's rule number one in
horror movies
this cat is very strange
me your hair hasn't become the wet your
whole life
[Music]
wow the dogs look great yeah no thanks
to you
my parents will probably ground him for
the next year it's like jail for kids
sounds like fake science
we're talking to characters from a book
and you're questioning fake science i'd
say one thing i'm going to do
we need more books
what i like books now